[Music]
I'm going to talk about building a data
stack in half an hour so this is going
to be like five minutes of me hammering
through a whole bunch of slides and me
attempting to do this live so we'll see
how that goes I've done this before but
I got an hour to do it I'll see if I can
do it in 30 minutes okay so a little bit
background so I am one of the
co-founders of mode Miller builds
products for data scientists and data
analysts and as a part of that we work
with a bunch of companies that are
trying to build out their data stacks so
they're building their data teams that
want to build to distribute analysis to
to their stakeholders and so there's
obviously prerequisite to that is is
building out a data stack and so we see
a lot of different things that companies
build so the first part of this is I
want to share kind of what that modern
stack looks like what is it that a lot
of companies are now building when they
think about building their data stack
from the ground up
so what does that look like it typically
looks something like this so here's a
really basic diagram of what that is
you've got a bunch of data sources on
the Left everything feeds into a data
warehouse and then some sort of
analytics platform on the right and so I
want to walk through kind of each one of
these pieces and the types of things
that we see the things we encourage
people to use and then you know I'll
actually run through setting these
different things up so the first part is
that central part which is thinking
about a data warehouse obviously that's
a core part of what you need to do you
need to build have a place to put all of
your data so what do you do there how do
you think about like which data
warehouse you choose a bunch of
different options out there different
things that we think are really
important to consider first of all you
want to be something that's really easy
to set up and maintain so when you're
especially when you're starting to build
this from go something that's
complicated often isn't worth it you
want something that you can actually get
up and running quickly and so things
like Hadoop or sort of the big data
systems often end up with stuff like
this where it's actually much more hard
much more difficult to set up then you
may initially think and so we typically
don't encourage folks to start set those
up especially if that's that's where
you're beginning ii encourage people to
use plain sequel that if you look at
like the popularity of sequel compared
to a bunch of other stuff that you could
do to to query databases if you were to
put like spark stuff up there to kind of
see the same trends that sequel is still
really popular and so if you're you're
wanting to access your data sequel's the
primary way to do it is what most
no we would encourage folks to use
something that's very sequel forward and
finally the ecosystem around this merely
matters when you're setting up a
database it's not it's not just the
database that you're using this is kind
of the hub of everything else that
you're using it's the hub of where the
data gets fed into it's the hub of the
applications that sit on top and you
want to have something with a really
robust ecosystem so that you can use all
these other tools and the ecosystem when
you're actually building this out um so
for this demo I'm gonna use redshift I'm
sure a lot of you are familiar with it
why do we choose redshift for this first
of all it's super simple to setup I'll
show that in just a moment
second it's based off a Postgres so it's
pretty straightforward it's no it's gone
space off a Postgres anyway
I'll see if this goes nope which is
which is like a standard wave of
standard sort of form of sequel that
most people know okay so
Postgres is based off a Postgres also
redshift has a really rich partner
ecosystem so there's a lot of different
tools out there you can use with it a
lot of things you can use in combination
with it other options that we have to
see folks use we see a lot of snowflake
these days also a lot of bigquery these
are kind of the three main things that
we see people evaluating or thinking
about databases the second part I have
to do is actually collect data so
there's kind of three major categories
of the data you typically want to feed
in the first is like web traffic data or
sort of generalized event streams for
this we often encourage folks to use a
tool like segment so segment is a web
tracking system you basically plug it on
your site it works is this kind of
routing layer you can kind of see how it
works here you track it of a buncha
different places it feeds into segments
and segments writes it to a bunch of
different tools one of those tools if
you see that little kind of icon on the
far right is redshift so it's really
easy to set up event tracking and write
it directly at redshift it's also super
simple you'll see this in a minute it's
easy to set up you just like add these
little tracking logs and that's all you
got to do and all like the api's and
stuff are really built out behind there
other options here are things like
snowplow and Google Analytics fitting
the theme of like snow stuff up top and
Google tools down the bottom so these
are also both event tracking systems
Google Analytics lets you write stuff
really easily to bigquery if that's what
you're using as well the other
categories of things are like
application databases or system
databases say you have databases and a
Postgres database my sequel things like
that you want to write that in your
warehouse or you have databases or data
and SAS applications they are using
Salesforce or intercom or Marketo things
like those sorts of places you might
want to write those places into your
centralized warehouse as well there are
some tools that really good for that one
of the general philosophies we like to
like to adhere to is to the ELT / the
ETL it simply basically pull the data
out write it in your warehouse as it is
and do transformations later this is
something that's like a little bit
controversial though this seems to be
the way the industry is mostly going not
talking a bunch of complicated
transformations in the process of
actually writing the data in the
warehouse so for the demo I'll use
stitch for this there are some other
tools out there that are really well
work really well as well but stitch
makes this really simple to connecting
things just requires you to like fill
out some basic forms so doesn't actually
take any work you can have data like
flowing in your house right away
similarly if this is how you can write
data from your Postgres database or any
other like application database into
we're into a warehouse like redshift all
you got to do is fill out these forms
and you're good to go some of the other
options so v train is popular there's
also a tool called at leap or ET leap
I'm not actually sure how they pronounce
it but these are options as well that
are kind of just as easy to set up third
step is cleaning and modeling data so
there's actually kind of this
intermediate bit that I left out off
this diagram that when you actually do
this one of the things you might want to
do is actually transform the data in the
warehouse so once you have like raw data
writing in from Salesforce you might
actually clean it up transform it and so
there's some ways we think about when
you want to be able to do that one it's
good to have that be written in plain
sequel a lot of transformations now are
written in sort of like data engineering
languages mostly primarily Python we
very much encourage folks to do that in
sequel the reason for that is because a
lot of your analysts are the folks we're
going to ultimately be writing these
pipelines and this is a blog post from
Jeff at stitch fix very much encouraging
folks to say hey analyst should be
actually the people writing those
pipelines not engineers and analysts are
the ones who who know sequel ii and i
think this is a really important point
that your transformation layer should be
agnostic to the downstream applications
you don't want have a transformation
layer that's designed for one
application or another it's good to have
something that any downstream
application can use the reason for that
is while this may be your initial stack
this is where you end up going and this
is actually what you're building on top
of you have things like ml pipelines and
and other marketing automation platforms
we have customer facing applications
there's a whole bunch of things you
actually want to use that data for and
if your transformation layer only talks
to one of them then you end up having to
replicate that transformation over and
over again for the demo we're gonna use
DBT DBT is an open-source bit of
technology that does this really well
there are some other options data form
who some folks are here downstairs as
well as airflow you can also do this as
well airflow also works as like a little
bit more of an orchestration and
scheduling engine but you can do some of
these transformations in airflow as well
the fourth thing you want to do is
actually analyze and share your results
like the point of getting all this data
in one place and and and centralizing it
isn't just to have it there it's also to
be able to do work on top of it to be
able to do analysis with it
so things that consider for that is one
you want to something that you can
deliver results really really quickly
that this is really the core value of
what a lot of analysts do so this is
from a Harvard Business Review article
talking about the value that analysts
really bring and speed is the value that
that like analysts really bring to your
company that's the like the highest
virtue as this says that they have and
so you want a tool that really enables
people to do that quickly that if it's
something that really slows them down
they can't answer questions quickly then
you're actually putting a lot of things
in a way also if you kind of over plan
where those things go they typically
don't work out that one of the easiest
ways to ruin sort of analytics
initiatives or data science initiatives
is develop this really long roadmap for
where you want it to be in nine months
rather than kind of slowly iterating
your way there and seeing what works and
what you learn from it and change again
as you go these kind of over planned
initiatives typically typically are
things that that you see kind of die
halfway through because the data doesn't
actually tell you what you thought it
was going to at the beginning second
thing and a theme theme here is also you
want this to you Bo to use plain sequel
that a lot of the folks that are been
using this whether or not they're
engineers product managers or analysts
are going to be knowing how to write
sequel you want your analytics tools to
be able to speak sequel as well so
they're accessible to a lot of people
your company and so this also it's like
the most popular thing among analysts
and data scientists even folks who would
consider sort of like the capital D data
scientists sequel appears much more
frequently on on Glassdoor ratings than
these other things so if you want an
accessible tool sequel first is
typically a good way to go and finally
one it's something that's really easy to
share that there was a talk this is
really great talk by by David Robinson
who was a
chief data scientist a data camp about
the unreasonable effectiveness of public
work and the idea here was basically
your work is no good unless it's shared
with other people he was talking about
this and the public domain but he had
this great slide which was essentially
the way he thinks about stuff is OK you
kind of like progress along the value of
your work but in reality nothing is
valuable if it's not shared and
everything is way way more valuable as
shared and so you want some way to
really easily share this work because
that's where all of the value there's
actually going to come and given to the
point of building this entire data stack
is to get to this end you want to help
people do that as quickly as possible um
so this is something mode does so I'm
gonna use mode for this example mode
does this because it's very much a
sequel first interface you have all kind
of the charting and stuff you want and
it's also really easy to share there are
other options for this as well so these
are a couple kind of like open source
tools that you can use as well for this
they're also free so you can use these
sorts of tools too if you want to be
able to quickly distribute this kind of
work so what comes next this is what I'm
not actually gonna get into when I share
this but the next sort of things you
would want to do are thinking about
ingesting more data sources how do you
like ingest more events dreams how do
you can ingest custom data sources
there's a lot of great tools out there
for this that you can already build on
top of this ecosystem so things like
fire Kinesis firehose but you try to
Amazon works really well for this it
makes it really easy to collect data
from a bunch of different sources to be
able to scale this stack out you may
also want to actually scale this up once
you start to have a lot more data you're
needed we need to be able to scale it up
redshift can do this really well there's
like with a click of a button you can
resize the cluster you can make make it
work with much larger data that's gonna
cost more which is a downside but Amazon
also has other paths here of things like
Athena which lets you work with data
directly on top of s3 and scales up to
something very very large so there's
options to take the stack and be able to
make it something that's that's scalable
kind of 2 to the size that they'd like
fortune 500 companies we need another
thing is thinking about data governance
like how do you lock down who can
control what who can see what there's a
lot of different solutions for this this
is something we kind of get into like
the IT world of analytics and data
science I'm not going to get into this
much but this is typically one of the
places where people start to think about
where they need to go once there they're
actually taking the stack a little bit
further so with that I'm actually gonna
walk through a demo of doing all of this
in like 15 minutes maybe
we'll see how it goes how that's gonna
work so I'm gonna set all this stuff up
the way this is gonna work is first I'm
gonna set up redshift one of the
downsides of this is there is a little
bit of like lag time if you set
something up and has to like spin up
machine somewhere and Virginia or
wherever so they're do you have to do a
wait a few minutes for some of these
things so I'm gonna like jump around a
little bit but we'll set up redshift set
up segments set up stitch to be able to
write on a redshift and set up segments
to write dated a redshift then I'll
connect mode so we can actually query
that date alive and then we'll set up
DBT if we wanted to go to those
transformations so for this I do have a
few things already existing I have an
AWS account because you don't watch me
fill out the AWS forms that's like
asking a bunch of stuff about what
company you work for and things like
that it's super boring I have an
application database and like a with
little web application that's pretty
basic now that I can show you and I
already have intercom integrated into it
so you can see how this works for the
third-party data source the other stuff
that I'm gonna set a bread shift from
scratch segments from scratch stitch
mode and DBT all from scratch so let's
see if we can do this without this whole
thing gone crazy alright let's see oh
geez get out of here get out of here
alright so this is the stuff this is the
stuff on the Left that we're gonna do so
here's what I've got so this is my like
fake company website it's a video
conferencing app so it's like this super
exciting webpage so this is what we're
gonna we're gonna start using to to set
up and it's got a little like intercom
widget down here somewhere
should be once it loads so it's a thing
that actually is like a fully
functioning fully functioning website so
the first thing I want to do is set up
redshift so here is in the 800s console
all I've got to do to do this let's just
click on redshift wait for the Internet
yeah um so they have this quick launch a
new cluster you do that you can define
some stuff I've got some stuff here that
I actually want to use for setting this
up so that I know what the name is we'll
call it that call it that will give it
this very exciting password
and that's really all you got to do so
then you click launch and now it's
starting to do with few things it's
gonna take a few minutes and so you can
see that there's creating this cluster
so that's all it takes
so the first part of this is simply
setting up redshift it's like filling
out a few basic forms and you're good to
go
the next thing I want to do though say I
want to start writing data from like my
website to this database so I want to
start recording events about when people
are viewing pages and writing that to to
my database so right now I'm not doing
that there's nothing here that's
connected this website to to that
database because I could make this a
little bigger so I can do that is
through through segment so like I said
like this shows you can like integrate a
bunch of stuff right at all two
different places
super easy so I will actually sign up
for a segment account maybe the button
works let's try a new chat all right
sign up for segment will get this email
address that's all of my stuff then
email address and this password sure
fake sure it's very small I'll be the
CEO an agency why not all right so I
don't have to verify an email address
which I can go over here let's go Gmail
my password again alright so that's all
it takes to sign up for segments you'll
see the first thing that it tells you to
do is connect some sources and so what I
want actually do is connect the source
from my website to write it to this
database so I got to do is click add
source say from a website I will call it
10 can I think that's what it was called
and now if I go to sources and click
here and it will give me this little
snippet of code so this little snippet
is all you got to add to add anything to
your website to be able to track it so
this will start recording a bunch of
different events about the people that
are coming to your site the pages
they've used some like metadata about
them the users things like their their
the IP address things like the browsers
they're using all those sorts of things
that can be super valuable for for
analytics so do that so there's all my
passwords to fake stuff so this is this
application that's running that website
all I gotta do is I hop over to this
thing just add this one little snippet
here oops and so if I save that and now
deploy it you could all judge me for my
console colors segment and this so now
this is gonna deploy to the website as
soon as this is up and running what's
gonna happen is just with that segments
is gonna start recording that data I'm
gonna start being able to track every
time somebody comes to this page they're
gonna be able to see like again all this
information about them that can be
useful for for me to better understand
what they're doing and if I want to
better understand those users and things
like that I now have all of that data
already writing into to a database
so as this deploys the other thing I
need to do on the segment side if my
redshift database is set up which we can
check the other thing I need to do is
connect redshift to segment which will
allow it sort of that's the first half
of the pipe and the other half the pipe
is is writing things from from segment
or from yeah from segment into redshift
so this thing is now set up so I can
click on this and now I have all this
information about about this database
you can see here's like the host and
things like that and so I want actually
copy this stick this into here because
this thing gets generated for the first
time when you write it I don't want that
alright and so now I want to connect
this database to two segments so those
events will start getting written from
segments into that database so they go
back here that's not what I want
so we go to destinations now I can add a
destination redshift and you'll see all
I have to do is fill out some of these
credentials so that was the host I had
database is DC demo and this password
alright so that's now connected so if I
go back over here and go to these
connections you will see that now I have
these two things connected and all I
need to do now is actually like turn
them on and I can do that
so hopping in a database selecting the
sinks sinks to sort sources to sync
which I think I have to go here check
this save it so now everything is all
connected so these things are you can
see there's data flowing from my website
and your redshift so in like five
minutes you can get a database set up
you can get actually data flowing into
that database live from from your
database I want to see if this actually
is working I can go over to the source
click on this segment has this nifty
little debugger tool and now if i
refresh this page if this thing is
actually like it takes some time for
like CD ends or something to update you
can see that page view came from here
and I can actually look at a bunch of
information about that page view so
there's like the IP address the browser
that I came from which is this Firefox
thing so all that stuff so everything
here now all of this data is actually
getting written into to redshift so if I
want to start querying that
understanding how people are actually
using my data or using my website I can
now do that
so the next thing I want to do is now I
want to write like application data they
don't just care about event data as to
care about like the calls that are
happening behind the scenes and other
things that are that's actually going on
in my warehouse that's that stuff that's
not coming from an event stream but may
be coming from data that's actually
powering this application that I have to
be to do that it's super simple as well
so stitch is one great way to do this
again there's a few other companies that
can do this
so say I want to sign up we'll do this
as well with my kind of fake stuff here
so sign up get this password
ten can password so once I have this set
up now I just need to do this basically
the same thing I did in stitch which is
adding new integrations and these will
write things from from say like intercom
or from other application databases into
and direction so the first thing I might
want to do is set up redshift ask
actually to ask me to do this stuff
first so let's set up intercom so I have
intercom on my site to be able to set
this up I can just call this intercom
and then just copy this little intercom
like app ID which is right from the URL
and I save it and then it'll spin for a
second your authorize it and yeah what
should be good to go so now it's
connected to intercom so stitches gonna
start pulling data out of intercom so
every time somebody writes a
conversation - intercom every time I new
help - a new ticket I'm actually gonna
start getting that written directly into
to my warehouse as well the next thing I
would need to do is set up the warehouse
itself which I can do here AWS user map
that to see demo spelled that right
so now it'll connect to to the redshift
database and now it handles all those
pipes for me and so what this means is
like all of these things these I've
built these systems before before these
tools existed it used to be something
that took a long time to set up it used
to be something that like we had
engineers maintaining ways just to sync
data from like Salesforce into a
database and now in like a matter of a
few minutes you can actually set all
this stuff up without like any
engineering need whatsoever it's
something that that I can all do like on
my own without without any help and so
now that data is being written into this
redshift database as well so these
pipelines are all live as well there's
things that that segment will write
directly in without me having to change
anything
intercom will write things directly and
without me having to change anything all
these things are set up and ready to go
without without me having to actually
maintain anything anymore
the next step here which I'm not gonna
actually bother with for the sake of
time is I could set up this an
integration from my post crest database
as well it happens in exactly the same
way so if this thing if the internet
here lives you could also set up a post
crest integration using the same stuff
and so if I click on this I'll just fill
out these forms I need to build to do
the exact same things so you'd be able
to have data from like a Postgres
database again updating live to be able
to start clearing it in and red ship the
next step is how do you actually start
working with this so this is mode if I
want to know sign up for mode I'll go
through the same process so if I just do
this
come on
firmer
sooo as soon as this happens this is
gonna take me through like a sign-up
flow to be able to connect the database
I'll fill out the same form again and
then I'm actually querying that database
live so again all this in a matter of
minutes I can actually be like working
off of live data coming from from my
website without without ever having to
like go through an engineer without
having to actually go through anything
that doesn't take just a few minutes so
the the last part of this so you can
kind of see how this works
which won't make you watch you fill out
this form one more time you'll get what
this looks like you fill it out and then
you start liking writing queries against
against this live starting be able to
build dashboards and charts and things
like that the what this actually will
look like as an end result I have here
as a sort of Julia Child in it in case
time ran out so you can build stuff like
this so this is on top of the data that
would be flowing in this is a live
dashboard against that data for this is
like around that call thing so you do to
look at stuff like the amount of calls
that are coming in the distribution of
those those call durations the amount of
time it takes to join all this stuff is
sitting directly on top of the same
infrastructure on top of a redshift
database that that already has some this
data loaded in because there's obviously
not gonna be a whole lot of events
populated from this thing I set up five
minutes ago so the last bit is say you
would actually build this transformation
pipeline so this is a place where DBT
works really well so DBT is you
basically write sequel queries the
sequel queries get populated in your
davidic database as views or tables and
it handles a lot of the pipelines and a
lot of the like how do you do the
dependency management from that if you
can write these queries say define it on
another table and then DBT will very
much manage that dependencies for you
this is finally super simple to set up
so all you have to do to be able to do
this is you run like one command here it
will initialize this DBT repo and then I
need to open this up and there will be a
place there's
there will be a place where you fill out
some database credentials here once you
fill these out then you can actually
start building these models directly
against your database and so what this
looks like is all you have to do here's
a simple model that it materializes for
you so this just got generated by that
DBT init command if I were to run this
it would actually run against that
redshift database start populating these
tables and so I can actually define
tables against those segment tables
against the intercom tables that I
created against other data in my
warehouse to be able to build out this
much more robust modeling system and
like start baking in business logic and
do what I want to do as well
and so all that would take me to do is
start writing these queries and then
there's some simple command line
commands that you can run to do it so I
think with that this was supposed to end
at 11:30 and so that's that's like the
full extent of what you need to do
there's obviously much deeper you can go
with this I can show more things if
people have questions but you actually
do all this like I said that was like in
20 minutes one of the things that's most
notable about this stack is it's
actually something that really scales so
we at mode modes like a hundred person
company this is minus redshift instead
of snowflake or snowflake instead of
redshift this is exactly what we use
like this is everything that we use to
be able to power the the data data
science teams behind 110 person company
and so rather than having to go out and
hire like an entire engineering team to
build this or even take like weeks and
weeks to spin this up it's something
that one person can sit down and do in
in 20 minutes there's a few things like
configurations you might want to deal
with like obviously I was doing all of
this with like a master user in a WSU no
era with redshift you don't wanna do
that but outside of that there's not
anything else you need to do to be able
to build something that scales with with
a company from five people to to 200-300
so with that I could wrap things up I
have like a question slide that doesn't
really mean anything but are there any
questions
in the context that you just you have to
employ what like our site has 200,000
concurrency
please really fall down is there like
so they all scale really well so segment
is used by a lot of like if you go to
their website it's used by a bunch of
like major media companies things like
like Fox and like 20th Century Fox and
folks like that they get tons and tons
of traffic so those scale extremely well
databases like redshift and snowflake
snowflake is very much an
enterprise-grade so is redshift
there will be times when cost becomes
prohibitive there on the redshift side
because redshift doesn't separate
storage from compute so if you're
storing sort of petabytes of like event
data redshift does become pretty
expensive but they have ways to actually
move that data off into s3 using either
Athena or something called spectrum
which lets you kind of like split the
difference and kind of get redshift on
top of s3 so it's it's like a pretty
simple transition to go from one to the
other mode scales well note so mode is
is basically querying the data where it
lives in your infrastructure so we don't
actually have to worry that much about
scale in that sense like the the data
processing scale mostly happens on your
infrastructure so it scales for us there
and stitch is one place where there can
be scale questions so say you're wanting
to replicate data from some like
production database that's particularly
huge stitches and SSL gonna be great for
that there are some other solutions
there but that's like getting into
replicating on the order of a lot like I
don't know tens of terabytes before you
start to have a problem which for most
things that you're using like that size
of data it's like an event stream
they're not gonna use it for anyway most
like application databases or third
party like SAS applications aren't
scaling to that to that extent so I I
don't know many folks who really run
into scale problems you run into scale
problems if your Netflix or Facebook or
Google or whatever but most of us aren't
that the last bit of them in terms of
cost do you do have to be aware like
there are some cost scales so segment
for instance will we'll get fairly
expensive though they have like lots of
you can once you get to that size you
can talk to them and they'll help out
all this stuff actually now is also
running for free this entire stack was
actually set up on top of tools that you
can initially use for free so none of
this actually would cost anything to do
today yes
they so they have like a cookie so
actually if I go to segment here this is
still up so they have this anonymous ID
so this is just a cookie from them so if
I were to like go back to that page in
the same browser if it was an incognito
browser they obviously can't they also
can tie into your own user ID so say
your application you log into then you
can pass that information to that and
that way you'd have awareness of it so
there's there's a lot of good stuff you
can do there about like jumping the
bridge between say a signup flow where
they will have a consistent anonymous ID
which is this like segment cookie
throughout the signup flow and then like
a user ID will show up on the in this
inside of the signup flow where it
wasn't showing up on the outside
no no yeah I even you couldn't you met
you could add custom tracking chief like
you can add custom properties of these
events so say you wanted added something
custom but people could clear your own
cookies too so it's sort of the same
problem
the
as in they don't to use as many tools or
they have a different stack they want to
integrate with so most of these tools
integrate fairly well with the major
players across the ecosystem so things
like snowflake bigquery redshift
Postgres if you're using that as a
warehouse which some people do spark in
some cases people are using them for
this most these tools integrate pretty
well with those so they kind of mix and
match across like the the major thing
segments works well with those stitch
and five trend can write to all those
things mode can connect to all those
every once in a while you'll run into
people who like probably the most common
thing is we're a [ __ ] shop for some
reason what do we do there there are
some ways to be able to handle that in
most cases what we encourage folks to do
is try to move into into this ecosystem
because everything is getting built
around it so if you're like using [ __ ]
what the problem is not only do you have
to deal with like the occasional
problems with using [ __ ] you have to
deal with nothing else gonna get built
for you these tools don't exist for you
and neither will future tools so there
are there are people who like working on
helping do those translations but for
the most part if you run into that it's
it's kind of helping migrate to to these
future things the other version of that
is like the very enterprise version of
we are on some like sequel server from
2008 and in those cases there's just
kind of you have to modernize to some
degree like most of these modern tools
are not going to get built for legacy
versions of sequel server or some Oracle
thing that hasn't been updated in a
decade
[Music]